В Україну вже масово завозять російську вакцину від коронавірусу -
про це заявляють деякі політики та лікарі, зокрема,
кардіохірург Борис Тодуров. За його словами, цілі родини в Україні
вже вкололи російську вакцину.
У міністерстві охорони здоров’я це заперечують і запевняють, що
не займаються поставками. Водночас очільник МОЗ Максим Степанов
не виключає закупівлю російської вакцини, але за умови,
якщо Всесвітня організація охорони здоров’я підтвердить її безпечність
та ефективність. Чи можна довіряти
російській вакцині від коронавірусу?
Російську вакцину назвали "Супутник V" на честь першого
космічного супутника, запущеного СРСР у 1957 році.
Це перша у світі офіційно зареєстрована
вакцина від коронавірусу.
Росіяни поспішили це зробити 11 серпня ще до проходження
третьої фази випробувань, яка передбачає тестування препарату
на декількох тисячах добровольців. Перші з п’яти тисяч добровольців
були вакциновані 9 вересня.
Це означає, що проміжні результати можуть бути оприлюднені
після 21 жовтня. Не чекаючи завершення третьої фази
випробувань, російські ЗМІ активно пропагують вакцину, розповідаючи,
що її вже вкололи міністр оборони Сергій Шойгу,
мер Москви Сергій Собянін та одна з доньок Путіна.
Зараз заявити, що ми першими винайшли вакцину
для внутрішнього порядку денного, - це сигнал того, що,
в принципі, ситуація під контролем. А на зовнішній порядок денний
це сигнал того, що Росія була і залишається першою багато в чому
і свою роль "рятівника" вона за собою залишає.
На початку вересня розробники російської вакцини оприлюднили
результати першої та другої фаз клінічних досліджень препарату,
стверджуючи, що все гаразд. Але у багатьох вчених є підозри
щодо можливих маніпуляцій даними. Близько 40 дослідників
з Європи, США, Канади і самої Росії у відкритому листі
ставлять під сумнів достовірність даних розробників вакцини.
Зокрема, науковці заявили про статистичні аномалії.
Особливо впадають в око повторювані комбінації чисел.
Різні учасники випробувань у різні дні мали абсолютно однаковий
рівень антитіл у крові. На думку міжнародних експертів,
не може бути простим збігом те, що показники Т-клітин,
які борються з коронавірусом, у тих, кому вкололи вакцину,
виявилися ідентичними. За словами відомого молекулярного біолога
Енріко Буччі, це все одно, що кидати жереб і кілька разів
отримувати ту саму послідовність чисел.
У Росії ж критику спростовують, але при цьому додаткових даних
не надають. Досі не оприлюднено дані досліджень на тваринах,
а також не надано точні характеристики людей, з якими
порівнювали рівень антитіл добровольців, яких вакцинували.
На західну критику Росія реагує не аргументами і доказами,
а, як написано на сайті вакцини, "боротьбою з кампанією
дезінформації про вакцину, яку розгорнули в низці міжнародних ЗМІ".
Вакцина вже пропонується одним країнам як гуманітарна допомога,
а деяким іншим - на продаж. Зокрема Бразилії можуть продати
мільйони доз вакцини, хоча її випробування ще не завершені.
На початку жовтня один з лідерів партії
"Опозиційна платформа - За життя" і кум Путіна Віктор Медведчук,
зустрівшись із російським президентом, демонстративно
похвалився тим, що вже вколов російську вакцину, і попросив
про поставки препарату в Україну.
Я хотів перед вам порушити питання про можливість розглянути те,
щоб ця вакцина в тому числі потрапила в Україну,
щоб українські громадяни в майбутньому були захищені
від цього страшного захворювання.
Так. Звісно. Чому ні? Якщо ми з Білоруссю почали цю роботу, то
можемо так само працювати і з Україною. Треба зі спеціалістами
з України зайнятися реалізацією цього плану. Треба, щоб
офіційна влада України відповідним чином сформулювала свої запити
і потреби. Ми до цієї роботи готові попри будь-які політичні складнощі.
Наразі не відомо, чи справді російська вакцина працює,
не кажучи вже про можливі серйозні побічні наслідки
від щеплення. Говорити про безпеку та ефективність "Супутника V"
ще зарано. Кремль його запустив, але чи не впаде цей супутник,
ніхто не знає.